what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so we are covering fantastic for
number two and this is cool because this
is like the the totality of Franklin
Richards powers in terms of like what
he's fully capable of and it's kind of
interesting because Dan Slott takes an
intriguing twist on the full abilities
of Franklin and what we'll talk more
about that as we sort of get through it
but this is kind of like the other half
of Fantastic Four number one right like
that has a four number one dealt with
like Johnny Storm and dealt with Ben
Grimm and so on and so forth and how
they were dealing with a fantastic four
being gone and then this one shows us
what was happening while they were doing
that but more of more so what the
Fantastic Four had been doing this
entire time now for those of you guys
who were kind of new to the whole Marvel
comics landscape and are picking up with
Fantastic Four essentially the the
multiverse was destroyed right like we
ended up basically learning that through
a combination of an experiment with the
molecule man Owen Reese and the
beyonders themselves the idea was to
destroy the entirety of the multiverse
and Doctor Doom and intervened he had
inadvertently eradicated a planet in
that quarter I guess it eradicated earth
and that destroyed the whole universe
and that led to like basically universes
bumping into each other who was called
the incursions and where that was
covered throughout the entirety of
Jonathan Hickman's
Avengers the New Avengers run once we
got to Secret Wars proper basically it
all kind of boiled down to a fight
between Reed and in and Victor Von Doom
sort of this this fight there was a long
time coming when Doctor Doom finally had
to admit that Reed was a better man than
him and then of course once that was all
said and done Reed Richards restored
everything back to normal and so
following that the Fantastic Four went
forward and just started creating
universes and that's what they've been
doing the entire time now if we're being
honest with ourselves Jonathan Hickman
Secret Wars was basically set in this
stage for a reboot I mean there's no way
you can argue the opposite like it was a
blank slate it was and now multiverses
or now universes are being made who
knows what form they're gonna take and
who knows what's gonna be there and it
was it was kind of weird but the fact
remains here that was a fantastic for
going through we don't really know about
all the universes they've made we just
really pick up on one universe in
particular now Marvel is still following
the numerical designation for universes
right like that was the old Captain
Britain stories when they introduced Jim
Jasper's the Omni versatile development
court Marvel wanted a way to be able to
distinguish one universe from another
and so within the story by Allen fine
and Alan Moore they said well the main
Marvel Universe is numerically
designated as earth-616 and that's how
that whole thing was born and so what we
end up doing is picking up with like
valaria and Franklin this is amit i want
you guys to notice there are a lot
they're basically into their teenage
years you know now if I were a betting
man I'd say they're probably around the
ages of like 15 16 years old somewhere
along those lines especially for valaria
because she's at the age now where she's
beginning to see boys in a different way
and so because of this valaria actually
has the attention of a particular alien
on this one world they've been creating
and Franklin's kind of given her a hard
time but it's a cool little thing
because this this is actually a really
really smart move by Dan Slott to do
this because when you're talking about
someone like valaria by and large ever
since she really made her appearance in
Marvel Comics back in the day she's
always just been the super genius
daughter of Reid right like that's why
the Fantastic Four were always kind of
like the center point of the of the
comic book universe is because valeri is
like the smartest person in the world
Marvel will kind of mess things around
those sort of shift things around and
say well at any one point in time
depending on what the story calls for
either it's Franklin or valaria or
Victor Von Doom that's like the smartest
person in the world but by and large
it's it's largely believed that valaria
is smarter than her father especially
being at such a young age and being
equal to her dad if not a little bit
smarter she'll certainly surpass him
somewhere along the line and so it's
kind of a funny thing to have them grow
up because it means you can start
shifting stories in a different
direction to where they kind of begin to
start looking at life differently they
go through the adolescent phase that
everybody else does now Reed begins to
pick up on what's going on Reed begins
to realize that his daughter is
immensely infatuated with this alien on
a different planet and as any
respectable father would do he would say
not my daughter so he snatches her up
and they leave that's not happening not
a chance
it's kind of a funny thing you know like
I know what I know what those alien boys
want I know what they're looking for
they're not gonna get it from my
daughter this kind of a protective
father mentality there but again this
goes into really kind of an explanation
of how this whole thing works and if
anything this is just kind of a
refresher you know from Dan Slott more
so than establishing a new a new status
quo when it comes to Franklin and and
the molecule man Franklin's powers are
in a lot of ways untrained he doesn't
have total control over them now that's
really left to like his older self when
he's an adult and to a degree his adult
self had traveled back to the past
during Johnathan Hickman's run of the
Fantastic Four and taught young Franklin
how to harness his abilities but only
did it in so far as here's how you hold
your power here's how you collect your
power I'm going to need it at a future
point in time so don't really use any of
it and that's
really all it was but it was kind of
taken Franklin on the tour and saying
this is what you're gonna be capable of
you are cosmic entity that how are you
possess is absolutely insane
now for for Owen Reese this is when
things get a little hairy with regards
to what dance Lots doing here oh and
Reese is really more of a painter than
the paint if that makes any sense
oh and Reese has the ability to
manipulate the universe but he can't
actually create a universe that's not
really something he can do he has he's
the molecule man which is really kind of
a misnomer
he's more akin to like the the atom man
but molecule man sounds better but he
controls the atomic structure of matter
so imagine like dr. Manhattan in the
Marvel Universe more or less which
inevitably is gonna lead to comments who
would win dr. Manhattan versus Owen
Reese versus the molecule man I have no
idea I have no clue guys like like put
your hand over your eyes grab a dart and
just throw it and just whichever one it
lands on is the one who would win I have
no earthly clue but uh but the fact
remains here that that Owen can't really
create things unto himself you know he
can't create something out of nothing
but Franklin Richards always had that
ability that was really established when
he created like a pocket universe ah
both in terms of Hickman's Fantastic
Four run as well as the events of like
heroes reborn so we've seen him do that
like a multitude of times and so it's
kind of weird because Owen basically
makes the case that Franklin Richards
can envision a universe but Owen himself
basically has to provide the molecules
and that's why this works because what
this means is that Owen Reese has his
power is so insane and it's so limitless
that wait what he used what he's
basically doing here is he's using his
own bodies his his own body for the most
part in creating universes out of it
it's like removing a piece of himself
and turning it into a universe v
Franklin Richards and visions so they're
two halves of the same coin working in
in tandem in order to achieve a certain
goal on the surface like it's kind of
funny because Dan Slott plays this off
as just a thing that's being done this
is an insane level of power
this is living tribunal the one above
all levels of power this is insane
like that's why it's so crazy to see it
just kind of be thrown out there is if
it doesn't really matter because it's
just it's just an enormous amount of
ability anyone either of these two guys
to give you guys perspective either of
these two guys could annihilate cosmic
entities it's crazy well maybe not
annihilate them but certainly like
challenge them and put up one hell of a
fight it's it's crazy like the level of
power that you see and that's why
whenever we have these discussions you
know we were where were we do these
stories where you're talking about like
cosmic entities and you're talking about
immense levels of power we've
they say that unless you have something
to juxtapose it to unless you have
contact so who's to say like Captain
America fighting someone like this or
like fan OHS without the Infinity
Gauntlet someone like fighting someone
like this you tend to kind of get lost
in the extreme nature of what they're
doing because there's nothing to really
compare it to it's just two guys who are
basically gods creating universes that's
really kind of all you have to go on and
so it's it's it's really cool to see
this happen because Franklin Richards
because his own imagination what he
envisions molecule man creates and so
it's cool because he's created universes
where almost all the planets are aquatic
planets he's created universes were
they're all like cave like planets he's
created all manner of different
universes envision them and then in turn
molecule man makes them now that's the
other important reason for why Franklin
is so powerful is because Franklin's
more of an architect it's not like a
child's mind creating insane things you
know it's all your child's imagination
run wild
he's not like four or five anymore if he
was that young these universes would be
absolutely insane he would be like the
infinity an owner if it was the infinity
revelation or ever when it was the jim
Starlin wrote where Thanos entered the
mind of Adam warlock and Adam warlock
enter the mind of Thanos and Adam
warlocks mind was more of like
completely structured and regimented and
there was no deviation and bad OSes war
was chaos and panic it's a really
interesting situation and so it's kind
of cool when it when it comes down to it
because it's just it's crazy levels of
power now when it comes to valaria this
is kind of a funny thing if she's
irritated because she can't talk to to a
Burroughs the guy that she wants to talk
to you on that on that and you know in
that other universe and this again kind
of hit to the nature of how smarter
character is what she's capable of and
Franklin kind of makes a comment well
maybe that's why dad landed here because
he didn't want you talking to strange
boys like he didn't like he didn't want
a valaria coming home one day saying hey
dad like I'm leaving I'm going to this
universe over here because I found a boy
I really like and we're gonna go get
married at the chapel Oh love in Vegas
in that universes version of Vegas but
in the middle of all this when when they
basically set to creating their new
universe Franklin Richards powers
stopped working now this is no small
thing what Reed does here is he sits
down and he literally analyzes his sons
powers like he analyzed them says look
your powers are still there for whatever
reason you can't create universes
anymore now this in truth at the outset
doesn't really seem to make a whole lot
of sense because when it when it gets
not really you know I guess envision
universe is more
but like the ability to kind of take
this this concept to take this this
universal energy this cosmic energy put
it into a form and then give it to Owen
Reese and then Owen Reese bringing it
into existence Franklin Richards can't
do that anymore
and again it doesn't really make a whole
lot of sense here because Franklin
Richards powers were never
compartmentalized right like they were
never divvied up like Franklin Richards
has telepathy but not telekinesis
Franklin Richards has reality-warping
but not telepathy his powers never
worked that way it was always just he's
wildly powerful and like the his powers
will become insane you know it at some
future point in time and he'll basically
become like God more or less he'll he'll
ascend to godhood and become a cosmic
entity what this is is it's almost like
saying Charles Xavier has telepathy but
he can't read minds the two go
hand-in-hand we can't really separate
one from the other and so again I mean
it kind of works for what for what dance
lots trying to achieve it works for the
purpose of the story in the sense that
Franklin you know this is kind of an
indication there's a much larger force
coming here and while they're analyzing
everything
they're basically beset by this being
that just kind of smashes in to the
universe and then declares herself as a
being called griever now this is Dan
Slott basically creating a cosmic entity
and that's so that's really the way this
goes and that's one of the things that's
kind of funny is people have a tendency
to look at stories right now in Marvel
Comics and say okay for the most part
the universe is fleshed out and so you
really can't create anything new because
there's nothing new to create and that's
true to a degree right like you really
can't write new stories because pretty
much every story that can be told has
been told all would really boil down to
is just retelling it retelling an older
story by shifting up characters that are
in it and just telling it a different
way Civil War too is a really good
example of that and so when you have
this whole scenario unfolding what you
what we have to keep in mind here for at
least all the new folks anyway what we
have to remember here is that back in
1961 1962 Jack Kirby and Stan Lee didn't
create like a template for the universe
and then say okay everyone go forward
and tell your stories it was just kind
of everybody was flying by the seat of
their pants and people like Roy Thomas
and Steve Englehart and Steve Gerber and
and Jack Kirby and Stan Lee and and
Chris Claremont and and all these
writers dance I'm sorry that Dan Slott
Dan Jergens you know all these people
were just kind of making it up as they
went along they were just kind of
creating these various entities in these
various beings for the purpose of
telling a particular story and so this
is how new cosmic entities are born now
whether or not any use is made out of
them Tom will only tell I mean that
that's really kind of the nature of
things you know like you had um Dan
Slott created a cosmic entity in Silver
Surfer
but she's never appeared since
she appeared in like the ultimate by Al
Ewing and then was never referenced
again and probably never will be but
that's just kind of the nature of how
these these events unfold and so it's
kind of crazy because what she does here
the first thing this being does the
griever does is she shows up and she
kills the molecule man and again this is
not a small thing because while the
molecule man isn't as powerful as he
used to be he's still insanely powerful
you know we've we've talked about his
power already in terms of how it is now
now with regards to how his powers now
you know in terms of that that
discussion I want you to keep that in
mind because back in the late 1980s the
molecule man was way more powerful than
that I mean the guy was like a
multiversal constant like his power
dwarfed the power of the Living Tribunal
I mean he was insane
like if you took fan OHS would be with
the Infinity Gauntlet and put him
against old-school molecule man from
back in the day oh he wouldn't he
wouldn't I laid him I mean like like
molecule man would annihilate Thanos it
wouldn't even be a contest because it
was stated time and time again that the
molecule man's power was so extreme he
could harness the very fundamental
forces of the universe and so he
basically was like a walking talking
Cosmic Cube he could manipulate time if
he got if his powers advanced to the
point that he could or if he learned how
to unlock that ability on the he could
manipulate time he'd given emulator
space he couldn't manipulate the
monitoring the whole nine yards you know
if it exists in the universe he could
control it that's how powerful he was
the problem was that after Secret Wars
to marvel realized just how powerful he
was and it was almost impossible to
write stories that basically managed to
God just deciding to fight the Fantastic
Four one day and so what we got was an
unofficial Secret Wars three that was
basically a kind of Fantastic Four like
like two shot and that went into
molecule man's powers basically being
reduced you know you were giving us like
the origin of him as being part of a
cosmic cube and so on and so forth and
then his powers being reduced so that he
wasn't really as capable as he used to
be and so if this was like old-school
molecule man from the late 1980s no way
this this cosmic entity destroys him but
because this is the newer version who's
weaker than he used to be it's entirely
possible but it's still a pretty
significant thing we saw that in in
aliens Ultimates right like when
Galactus approaches the molecule man
Galactus is scared out of his wits
because he's just like this is a guy who
could just annihilate me with a simple
thought like like you know I as Galactus
this insane being of immense power could
just be wiped away with with what
amounts like a breath if this this if
the molecule man so chose to take me out
like that and so then you turn around
and you have someone that powerful
who's just annihilated in the blink of
an eye and that shows you the kind of
power this being has and so from there
the Fantastic Four do the only thing
they can do which is to flee as fast as
they can because following this all
these threaten universes begin cracking
and shattering and falling apart it's
kind of the collapse of the unit of the
multiverse all over again
now this can be interpreted in a couple
different ways there are some who will
look at this and say okay because of the
powers of the griever wields she's like
the marquee of death right just like
waving her hand and destroying universes
but I would look at this and say I don't
think that's the case instead what I
would say here is that because all these
universes were basically universes that
were tied into the molecule man because
it was basically his own life energy
more or less his own molecules that were
creating these universes when he was
destroyed those molecules went with it
and so it's like kicking the foundation
out from under a building of course is
gonna come crashing down because the
systems of support are no longer there
and so that's that's kind of how I would
I would view this whole situation but
regardless of how you choose to view
that everything is crashing down again
now the way that that Dan Slott
Wrightsville area here is actually a
little strange because what is up
happening is that we're reading
companies say look we have to travel to
like this one particular universe in
order to because it's the best anchored
and then from there formulate a plan and
figure out how to how to take this woman
out valaria commandeered the ship and
flies back over to where a bro says to
the guy that should the boy that she
likes and then in turn is like I did
this essentially because of love because
she's in because she's in love with him
and because for her it's it's really
more of an emotional decision
historically speaking and depending on
how you view the Fantastic Four for
old-school fans they wouldn't like it
any too much and the reason why is
because Valyria is essentially one of
the three smartest people in the Marvel
Universe I would argue she's the
smartest but depending on what the story
calls for sometimes it's doomed
sometimes it's Reed Richards so if you
can just kind of say she's one of the
three smartest people in the untidy
demova universe but she's governed by
reason and logic she doesn't really get
emotional it's one of the major traits
of her character now we can kind of
chalk this up to Dan Slott saying yeah
but like she's in her teenage years
though and as anybody will tell you when
you're a teenager logic is the last
thing that crosses your mind you are
emotional your hormones are running wild
all those different things and so it
kind of makes sense that she would like
fall prey to the natural biological
evolution of human beings and that her
hormones will go crazy she's a love with
a boy and she wants to go see him it
kind of makes sense and so what it does
is it leads to the to the rest of the
Fantastic Four
- Franklin forming a plan because
Franklin's response is a
believe you killed Owen Reese I'm gonna
use every ounce of my power to
annihilate you and to basically wipe you
from the face of existence and she just
kind of flicks her finger and that's the
end of Franklin but he just comes
crashing down he's not dead
but he just comes crashing down he is
he's basically crushed that fast and
that easily by this person again not a
small thing
you're talking about a character who in
the future will have power that's so
extreme
he'll resurrect Galactus from the dead
it's mind-boggling when you think about
this this kind of thing in relation to
like all the power that you see and
Marvel and so from here it looks pretty
wild in in in this whole scenario
because what she ends up doing is it is
almost kind of it's almost like she's a
little cocky and a little arrogant
because Reed says like you know
ultimately will defeat will find a way
to win you know and that kind of a thing
and so she sort of gets carried away
with herself the grievers says well then
fine here's a device this is basically a
multiversal transporter this will
transport you anywhere or transport
anything here and so it's just kind of
like fleet run do whatever you want to
do but ultimately I'm going to destroy
everything and I'm going to watch on I'm
going to grieve as you and everyone in
every universe you've ever cared about
they Eve ever maid comes burning down
around you and so in response Reed
Richards it really kind of picks up with
like the tail end of Fantastic Four
number one where Reed is like assembling
this device basically given this this
device together putting it together and
then putting it to use fires out a force
signal to the main Marvel Universe and
then teleports Johnny Storm Ben Grimm to
this planet he's on all alongside all
the other extended family members of the
Fantastic Four and so the reason why
this happened is the kind of a funny
thing because at the outset when I saw
this I was like oh my god he just
teleported all of her superheroes to
this world and they're all gonna fight
this being these are all people who have
been part of the Future Foundation the
ant-man Scott Lang was part of the
Future Foundation you had Ben Graham of
course and you have Johnny Storm were
part of the Fantastic Four but you have
like she-hulk who stood in for Ben Grimm
at one point it's actually kind of an
interesting scenario what Marvel did
after the events of the original Secret
Wars this story was designed to kind of
shake up the landscape so 1984 comes
around Jim shooter rights Secret Wars
Ben Grimm decides to stay behind because
he had fallen in love with a woman on
the planet he was on and then when
everything ended I want to say she died
or something like that so he left the
Fantastic Four team and it was Marvel's
way of bringing in she-hulk and trying
to make her relevant by having her be a
stand-in for Ben Grimm and it worked
incredibly well it was actually some
pretty damn good storytelling when it
came to her being part of the part of
the Fantastic Four there's also one of
the things that segwayed into John
Byrne's run it made John Byrne's one I'm
pretty sure John Byrne's run with
after Secret Wars I'm Peter Parker tried
to join the Fantastic Four in the first
in the in amazing spider-man number one
he was turned down and then eventually
became part of the Future Foundation
T'Challa
he'll like like all these characters all
these people in some form or fashion
have been a member of the Fantastic Four
community now it's not the most powerful
beings there because a Fantastic Four
were never about being powerhouses they
were never about being like the x-men
right you know was just like we have
godly powerful characters here that are
just gonna sit in the house all day long
and read people's minds like weirdos it
was it was never like that it was more
of like explorers it was more of getting
out there and exploring things and
seeing what the universe was about so
that's why you don't see people here
like a Magneto
like Matthew Malloy somehow resurrected
from the dead or you don't see like you
know these these insanely powerful
beings Galactus you don't see him here
you don't see the Silver Surfer because
it's basically just like people who have
been part of the Fantastic Four team but
it's a cool thing because now everyone
is for the most part aware the Fantastic
Four are alive that Reed Richards Susan
storm Ben Grimm that they're all
basically alive they're continuing on
their escapades and so at this point
it's only a matter of time before they
make their return but with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end if you are new here two
comments explained make sure you guys at
the sub button to become part of the rod
core if you guys enjoy this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later peace
[Music]
you